how's it going my name's Daniel Reynolds
I'm a public school teacher at Buffalo
Public Schools as talking about
computation Jokke today and that's using
um control surfaces like I'm turntables
and MIDI controls in order to let youth
control scientific and mathematical
visualizations and they think it could
help in education so thank you very much
so this is um computation jockey for
education outreach and expression and
it's going to be by me Daniel Rockwoods
Reynolds um from Buffalo Public Schools
I got a um degree and teaching I che
teach English as second language and I'm
in a math classroom and I got a lot of
stem initiatives and um someone
Christopher Nicolai he had helped me
with the some of the technical demo so
what is computation jockey basically it
is um the idea that you could you know
DJs they're very quick at going from one
song if you stop the record they don't
like it you know what I mean because you
have to keep it going at the party and
sometimes when you're doing a
presentation or something you got to
stop and you know fix something I want
you be able to compute sometimes they
say driving computation like a caddy if
you know what that means like a Cadillac
you're just going through you can
control anything in real time no
problems we were doing the theoretical
underpinnings when I was a kid I just
remembered this quote I said what's a
never I play it's got to be funky by
James Brown but when I looked it up it
turns out there's no results for what's
an ever funky it turns out they say what
he was saying
what's it ever I play it's got to be
funky but I had already started because
I usually use what's in evident funky
and a couple sentences a day so it's
kind of funny that that isn't known on
Google but this was me on first I I was
worried I said if it's not what's than
ever I still my theoretical you know we
just had you know these Univ a lanai
mathematics are my foundations wrong you
know for funkiness and Wolfram and all
that but on my friend Christopher help
me for the top roof was my my original
for what's a never but he helped me sync
it up with on whatever whatever
so even if what's 'never isn't a word I
think Oh theoretical underpinnings are
still sound so now um I looked at
Wolfram funky and only a couple of these
are from Wolfram like they said they
found a funky funky formula funky
integrals some of their Wolfram Alpha
you see is the fourth one down another
impressive release so we got some
Wolfram I even got to find Wolfram
Branca stop your fever and boofer monkey
is pretty cool and always really
influenced me so you know that's kind of
kismet of um looking up things on
YouTube um Google is but we want a
hundred percent of these top 100
searches you know to be Wolfram so when
my friend Christopher helped me um
helped me do is we make the Wolfram
funcle' meter and it's scraping the top
hundred searches to see how many are
related to Wolfram on the company so is
the top 100 searches go up the Wolfram
funkin meter is gonna update in real
time so that's our goal for the year is
to try and get it to like about 90% of
the Wolfram funky searches are really
about them Stephen Wolfram and his
company and all that so um I used to do
one I did a lot of hip hop education if
you go to this notebook and get the
links you'll see some hip hop UB hip hop
that's University at Buffalo hip hop I
was trying to keep teach kids and may
positive social change music about
stopping violence and cleaning up
recreational spaces and stuff like that
and people are saying you can't teach
them like it's good you're teaching them
about being socially conscious about
clean recreational spaces but how are
you gonna teach them science they can't
pass the exams but I was seeing a guy
GZA from the wu-tang clan was speaking
at MIT and Harvard I spell talking wrong
but I was typing this morning about STEM
education you can go there a guy on
Christopher emdin who was working with
Obama even before was a guest speaker at
our school so I'm about hip hop and all
that so we need to make computation
funky to reach the kids well let's look
at the word psychedelic for a minute and
nothing about like any substances or
anything it's about making one's mind
visible like your psyche and that's what
I want to help the kids be able to
portray
their minds on a screen in real time and
to projecting one soul/psyche can mean
mind or salt is a few different ways to
UM translate the you know the roots and
everything here's a quote from Nam June
Paik he's the UM called a founder of
video art he was doing CRT art and
everything back in his 60s
said we are not yet aware that telepathy
is conveyed through the resonance
factors of the mind and the
electromagnetic vibration of the head
might lead to a electronic Zen we can
read that in a book on video art by Jody
aku who died recently and is called it's
a psychedelic lineage of wolfram all
these are really mind expanding um
colorful graphics from this mathematical
graphics by Tom Whitcomb Jones when I
saw that cover and inside um back in the
day I was like wow I wanna you know make
this real-time crazy stuff grafica
grafica two different artists Michael
trot and we also had on you know the
mathematical journals and all that you
know here's um Einstein a go-go here
with his um looking cool the first
Wolfram webpage looks all you know also
looks pretty trippy looking here's some
literature that was influencing me the
first book was on influencing me was
mathematical basis of the artist by
Joseph Schillinger I had read that book
and then Marshall McLuhan understanding
media expanded cinema by Jean Youngblood
as a classic of video art with um
Buckminster Fuller doing the intro and
hyper animation was a book on you know
museum quality art of this kind here's
to good books recently chromatic
algorithms all about um video art and
chromaticity also the emergence of video
processing tools is two volumes set and
I actually got a quote from that one
says a history of conceptual filmmaking
without computer on and on motion
graphics are inextricably connected it
kind of ties in video art and the
computer art of the days back in the
sixties and all that 70s
here's some pioneering video art
examples bill Etra was a video artist
and he was using biofeedback to animate
a heart all the way back into 70s and
now I know Stephen collects a lot of
biofeedback data and all
and we can try and do it now a couple
decades later Nam June Paik he had the
first worldwide satellite art that was
coming from France and and in the US and
all around the world
it was beaming back into 80s and I'd
like to do you know some real like
hollow metric art actually I'm IMAX even
contacted me yesterday I hope in the
future we could partner with some GPU on
partners and do high-end visualization
contests where youth could um be in a
real like the full IMAX quality in
stereoscopy and be competing doing alms
shows of stem outreach with computation
jockey and this was a friend of my mind
my ryan who was the first kid in our
school to get into um the university of
buffalo gifted math program but
unfortunately he um he's always on take
different substances and stuff he was on
my best friend's and he actually passed
away and and he used to try and like
expand his mind by taking things and I
think maybe this could be a way that
kids wouldn't turn to drugs they could
try to you know expand their mind
through using control boards so that's I
think it even maybe save some lives or
something help gives some of that um
common confusion of you know youth and
all that development milestones we got
on positive stories of stem I spoke at
Armagh at a new school in New York City
on this idea outlining it and then last
year I spoke at a technology conference
and one thing Chris roni from the
Mathematica symposium there last year at
new school here's Stephen you know mixed
in with some triangulations in the back
ethica college I was spoke for one hour
is one of their main speakers at the ed
tech day at the wolfram summer school
where I am was getting the different
MIDI devices going in I had a nice did a
little residency and uh Somerville
outside Boston for three weeks after
summer school developing the topics more
and then at Buffalo infringment festival
I was on at a local mall there
the main place mall I was DJ I'm doing
CJ using some wolfram CAS and stuff and
trying to use it in a classroom as well
see how y'all are on time okay so next
slide um telematic and actually um I'm
gonna use a whole bunch of um quotes
from Parliament Funkadelic
because I have actually six quotes I
don't know if I missed any but who's
ever heard of on Parliament and
Funkadelic before here yeah I've got um
so I've got a couple quotes
the first one is you'd be surprised how
much some science and stuff and tech is
in some of their lyrics
so there's untie dog in the telematics
society in your average Huckleberry
Hound from George Clinton's atomic dog
and it's basically like you know
telematics through the telephone lines
and all this and we still have ever you
know our basic instincts that's what you
know the dog and all that inside you is
but the telematic on future of the world
you know how do we take our primitive
nature and bring it into the modern
society no Steven was saying at the
summer school that Roger Penrose writes
real good mathematical code but but you
know like here's some clips that he's
I'm talking he's always using you know
overhead projectors and stuff so one of
my goals is to get Roger Penrose to be
sort of CJ some of his talks coming up
so that's one of my goals for the year
here I got a quote I was ever heard of
Johnny Tong he worked on boundedness of
primes well anyway he's here interview
with David Eisenbud from mathematical
science Research Institute and David was
asking him we're talking before about
how you think about numbers and I
thought it was interesting so how do you
see numbers and Johnny Tong says you
know I see the numbers in my mind or I
say in my brain but how the situation
the position of the numbers it's very
hard to say I got some very strange
feeling like the numbers appearing in a
line maybe like the matrix maybe like
the cube or something like this I have
such a feeling is hard to tell by words
so I think using stuff like this people
could express in their mind you know
what they see when they have
mathematical visualization you know
sometimes you have higher dimensional
understandings and all this and this
could be a way to express it I got a
song another Parliament one I count the
moments we were apart and add them up
mathematically
and multiply them by the kisses I've
been missing supposedly divided by the
attention not to mention the affection
subtract that from your growth potential
and see I ain't miss and none because
any percentage of you is as good as a
whole pie and any fraction thereof
returns dividends of interest yes any
percentage of you is as good as the
whole pie in any fraction there are
returns dividends of love and I really
love math and that's basically you know
why I'm here and I want to share that
with the kids I wouldn't be showing some
real-time fractal generation I'm coming
up this is the Mathematica code we are
using on OpenGL my friend Christopher
Nikolai helped me um and this is we're
taking on a generalized form of the
Mandelbrot set has anyone ever heard of
um like Z like anything like z ii plus c
or anything like that currently if you
use Mandelbrot plot or Julia set plot if
you put in some of the non integer
exponents
it'll um it won't work so this is what
workaround that we did it so you can
smoothly move the boundary even in a non
integer exponents and I'm gonna show
that a little later in a tech demo I
just want to finish the talk see whom we
are in time okay here's some some more
parliament quotes J you know just I said
I had six so psycho alpha disco beta bio
aqua du Loup and everyone's talking
about do loops at Wolfram I mean all the
time so psycho alpha disco beta bio
human you loop you know what is the loop
that you know as our bio understanding
spirit for aqua boogie and you know
think about a lot about water how it
effects I'm interested in protein
folding and maybe the fact that on
hydrophilic you know that has going on
with it so let's see he was on dr.
Funkenstein who's ever heard of dr.
Funkenstein I when I heard this song
when I was a kid and really wanted me to
study atoms and molecules you know so he
says when I started turning and burning
and turning I'll make your atoms move so
fast expanding your molecules causing a
friction fire burning you on your
neutron causing you to scream hit me in
a proton baby there was some dr.
Funkenstein I'm from Parliament yeah
who's ever heard Iggy Azalea she's like
a rapper I think she's from like from
Down Under and all that first things
first sound a real
drop this and let the whole world feel
this I'm still in the Murda bizness I'll
hold you down like I'm givin lessons in
physics
so maybe Iggy Azalea could come up show
us you know how I'm gravity works but
some CJ out at one of her shows and I
was trying to compare with Leonard
Susskind here now almost everything if
you change it very much to charge the
electron the mass of this is that
particle I constants of nature and how
strong gravity and if you change by a
few percent 10% some 20 percent some 30
you'd really be in trouble and universe
would not look how it does so I wanna
I'm trying to create modules where the
kids could actually turn the knobs and
see you know how changing the physical
constants a simulation of how the world
might be different and maybe I'll show
that next year I'm still working on it
um how many slides we go okay this is
the last slide basically so the
conclusion is we now have the potential
to build the ultimate art station that
video and visioning artists have been
looking for and Wolfram language with CJ
concepts have the potential to cap this
off with stem and here's a quote I want
to share from a guy bill Etra who built
one of the first on video synthesizers
and he says he's talking about the early
days of tea leaptv lab in New York and a
peck at a pike Ave synthesizer you can
see this with there's some images this
is one of the first video tensor cisors
and he says that this guy Stan
Breckenridge I came through a lab and
namjoon was there showing off his
synthesizer and he'd taken color yolks
TV yolks put it over a smaller black and
white yolks they could distort the audio
signals and yet all these electronic
oscillators and stuff and his total
chaos and the colorizer was from a sony
camera and quarter encoder and they had
three extra inputs or the RGB I also had
cyan magenta and yellow inputs and they
could on go through the oscillator and
had various pictures in and then he
turns the namjoon and says can you make
a tree and namjoon he was also a
philosopher yeah people thought he was
crazy and he used to put subtitles on
when he spoke English but he had a
degree you know in philosophy from June
University German University he spoke
four languages fluently and he turns
back and says too young still too young
the meaning is we could do all these
oscillations and all these abstract
patterns as you can see on the image
and is and but we couldn't do a tree at
that point and I think now you know I
saw yesterday and I'm Charles poos
talked he was talking about geometry he
typed in he pulled up a mesh just by
typing it in a Beethoven you know so I
think if you can load up a table I
masturbate oven you could pull up a
master of a tree you know what I mean
whether it's a fractal tree or any other
type of tree probably most trees have
some fractal aspect so that's why I
think we finally built it and here's
like a little picture of astral
projections this was something done in a
planetarium at Rochester Strasbourg
planetarium by Bill d'etre back way back
in the day and you know I'd like to do
more events like this where people could
you know like to project their mind I'm
using these tools I got some challenges
because basically I think the only way
to get people to like also do this would
be to like challenge them so if anybody
can do any of these and really make it
look good I'm gonna give you a two
hundred dollar controller so the first
person to do any of these to my
satisfaction will get a $200 MIDI
controller called Q Neil and I'm also
going to give you a special printed
certificate from the CJ contribution to
the community and I'll also give you a
abstract artwork that I drew so if you
do any of these so you can make a song
called hip hop vibration so um you could
do some sort of protein folding with
MIDI controls you know turning the knobs
you could have different states are
folding based on the different models
they got you can scratch real Lego data
just scratching you know the neutron
star collusion could come in and out is
you're like couple scratching you could
find a funky curve from what I used to
searching wolfram funky one of those was
about a funky curve you could make it a
visualization you could take the song
computer love by zap and then have stuff
you can either emulate old computers or
you could have something about old
computer history you could take craft
work song pocket calculator and use the
inspire and you could be controlling all
the visuals with that see if you can do
that you could map rotations in real
time so instead of looking at videos of
polytopes being projected and like
symmetries like monster group you could
turn
the knobs and in real time you know look
for things in those um polytopes and and
groups and also any other legitimate
advance you come up with your own idea
based on what I said and you submit it
to me you can you can write to Wolfram
company and ask for me and say you're
submitting and I'll give you an artwork
and a certificate so basically I was
going to do a demo this turntable may or
may not be working but you see how I've
got this up here on the honest it's
called a MIDI controller and it sent
this is a XY grid is from something
called on a chaos later Pro and also
have another another controller here on
the floor and when I step on the
different controls and move them they
are ascending to this computer right
over here and so I'm gonna do a demo
maybe while I'm setting up the demo I
don't know if anybody wants to ask
questions cuz I think I gotta move some
things I don't know if someone wants to
pass this around or something you can
ask the quest
there's only one mic so you can shout
out a question and while I'm setting it
up basically you can shout out a
question
okay if there's no questions you can
just like sit there and wait for me to
get this going for the up ten more
minutes
if they see this computer had been
unplugging it ran out of battery so
that's why there's no questions nobody's
got any questions at all nothing um
nothing to ask
so lucky we got these on a couple of
minutes to get this going
five minutes yeah um basically I've
shown it I've only shown it to a few
classes like I was teaching him a
mathematical programming class at on a
school in my district and I showed it to
him but it's really just getting started
so basically you know I presented a lot
but having youth actually use it is just
starting to come out and I um I think
that I wanted to be for adults too
that's why I showed people like Roger
Penrose and them is I really think if
you have a mathematical idea you could
you know you could show it using these
devices and they're really in real time
and once they're saw this demo Stars up
it'll it'll be going
so this website that I'm going to show
you the fractal it's man Daleks and I'll
load it up here so I type in this um I
type in men a comm slash photo and this
is OpenGL reading from Islam it's using
on the Wolfram Web API to call for the
for the complex expand I showed you the
cold earlier and it gives me a cold
blend and on this computer which is had
run out of batteries I have to type
blend and all of my MIDI stuff and my
turntable are going into here on the
Linux system and and then when when that
goes I can actually send it I'm through
the servers into arm and to on here with
this thing having right now we might not
be able to do the demo so so I might
have to do it downstairs and show you
yeah I got power but this isn't my
system and if I hadn't run out it like
there's a couple different operating
systems on here and I keep trying to
load two different ones
see how much time we got yeah I probably
got to go down about two minutes right
okay okay
I'm just texting this okay my phone yeah
I'm just taking this guy asking which I
operate any other system
okay now it's on now I came up luckily I
don't think I'll be able to show you the
turntable because it um it's not reading
it right now but I'll show you the MIDI
at least washy let's see if I put a
needle on hopefully
so like I said all of these are going
through and I'm reading it here and
you're about to see this fractal change
I have to get the cold again and then
once that changes maybe I'll set up
downstairs or something for the for the
rest of the day anyone remember the five
letter word that had said before
okay our rows so anybody want to come up
in they can be my volunteer and it'll be
a last name
how about how about somebody just comes
up I'm gonna drag you drag you out up
here I'm not allowed to drag you because
that's called assault but I was hoping I
would scare you into coming up um just
come up you can um so I'm gonna press
this to show you what the other screen
is doing um I was hoping to show you
some video feedback art and stuff on the
fractals but with this technical
technical and I also have Christopher's
waiting over and um and buffalo he was
gonna control some stuff live too but
with all these arm there's some video a
few higher path
so here's how I map it so every when I
move this you see this is written in j/s
and remember the important thing for the
Wolfram language is that the fractal
that these values are going to affect
and I can load different fractals are
all um without the complex expand it
wouldn't be possible so so basically I
just some click on here and map it and
then like for like I'll choose power
lets see Z power ok so now it's mapped
and you see now when I switch to the
other fractal really cool okay now look
what happens it's changing the power on
my they got this little screen here at
barking it but you see it's actually
changing the visualization is not I'll
switch to a different fractal now and
these are different freckles that we've
we saved on the presets would anybody
like to come up and actually change the
fractal with their and you remember is
going to this Linux computer Christopher
if you can hear me these guys waiting in
Buffalo if you can hear me your your
password is um dizzy your password is
dizzy if you see something moving on
there someone's changing it in Buffalo
so endemic so let's have one person just
one person come up and change the thing
like I just want you know I mean I
shouldn't be the only one but you can
see it is doing it and it's doing it
well here I'm pressing some stuff down
here just move your um your hand around
there and that's just one variable
that's the exponent on Z but we can
actually um you know map like twenty or
thirty different things you could X
offset Y offset you can make it more
chunky that's how many iterations and
the graininess of it we can actually um
we can take CA s so he's got that going
and if we had like I'm saying people can
change stuff from other places so is on
rule 30 and when I click here it'll get
should give me a rule 30 tiled do you
want to mute let's see okay
well since that's not exactly Mandelbrot
set but let's do a song me and him
called it's a Mandelbrot's is a man oh
[Music]
[Music]
man
I think we party all the time but I
appreciate everyone for coming
hope you can see the potential and have
a good night
[Applause]
and knowing that normal thanks